[Music]
as you move to the cloud and adopt the
latest technology such as kubernetes
have you found it even harder to find
the root cause of issues and understand
just how well your application is
performing stackdriver
application performance management aka
APM shines light on your cloud native
and multi cloud environments in order to
help you solve these problems better i'm
brian zimmerman
product manager for trace & debugger and
i'm morgan mcclain product manager for
stackdriver profiler stackdriver is
Google's suite of management and
observability products APM is focused on
that deeper levels of debug style
information to help reduce mean time to
resolution find performance
optimizations and build the best
possible experience for your users APM
features three products stack driver
trace stack driver profiler and stack
driver debugger traces are distributing
tracing product what is distributed
tracing you ask well tracing allows you
to visualize how a request flows through
your environment in microservices
applications or highly distributed
environments understanding context and
flow is essential to resolving problems
how do we use this in real life
for example let's assume that we receive
an alert that shows a jump in latency
for our application trace gives us the
best detailed data to help us up
troubleshoot this error with stackdriver
trace you can easily see the top
requests RPC calls and associated
latency find an example of the issue
you're having with simple search and
filter and see a simple view of the
request as a processes through your
complex environment this includes
detailed custom information and
annotations for more detailed
information and analysis reports are
generated automatically you can view an
existing report or create your own to
see how latency has changed over time
you can group these by percentile and
you can also drill down and into example
traces to find out exactly what happened
to cause decision as you can see trace
guides you from problem to service now
we will show you how you can get from
service to method with stack driver
profiler profiler can inspect the CPU
and memory performance of all the
functions in your code and it shows you
the calling relationships between them
profiler can visualize your code on a
flame graph which shows calling
relationships along the vertical axis
and resource consumption on the
horizontal axis you can use a number of
different filters including weight
filtering which only shows data captured
during periods of high consumption and a
focus filter which shows all the paths
in and out of a selected function if you
need to visualize the performance of
functions that are called to write your
code base you can use the focus table
which shows the aggregated cost of all
the functions in the graph finally once
you've identified the area of code that
you're interested in it's time to
inspect the behavior of this code to
find the problem this is where debugger
comes in stackdriver debugger offers the
ability to take lock points and
snapshots of your running code in
production without impact redeploying or
restarting your services traditionally
debugging involves analyzing logs and
metrics taking a guess at the problem
deploying some new code or a debug
module looking at the logs again to
confirm waiting for the issue analyzing
logs again perhaps taking another crack
at it
stackdriver debugger allows you to take
breakpoints and snapshots in production
without system impact redeploying or
restarting your application this allows
you to tighten your troubleshooting flow
significantly as you're not having to
wait for lengthy deployments in addition
to the efficiency gains many customers
report being able to bring debugging
further up the troubleshooting stack to
operators or sres further reducing MTTR
an affecting customer impact all of
these APM tools work of code and apps
that are running on any cloud or even
on-premise infrastructure so no matter
where you run your application you now
have a consistent accessible APM toolkit
to monitor and manage the performance of
your apps with stack driver trace
profiler and debugger APM enables
developers and operators to track and
resolve issues the way that Google site
reliability engineering does you can
start and stop your code without
affecting your users and get insights
into how your code is running on
production no matter what cloud you're
using whether your application is just
getting off the ground or if it's
already live in in production using APM
to monitor and tuna's performance can be
a game changer to get started or stack
driver APM simply link the appropriate
libraries for each tool to your
application and then start gathering
telemetry for analysis to learn more
visit cloud.oracle.com
[Music]